welcome to bananamores bananamores makes
me hungry for more comedians like this
next one
thank you so much mitzi for having me um
my name is maya bishmuk um i will be
doing some characters today
i do hate myself so i like to play other
people it's a lot easier that way
you'll be happy i'll be happy we'll all
be happy together
so let's just go through some of my
favorite pandemic
characters of the year you know her
you hate her she's the preachy
privileged one
i know this is a super trying time
but guess what i found that it's brought
me a lot of purpose and meaning
plus i'm rich and my parents have land
and i've been focusing on my hobbies
like picking out ethnic tapestries and
making indian food using my pantry
staples
plus financially i know it's hard for a
lot of people but i'm utilizing the
government
i've just taken out my fit ppp loan for
17 million dollars
for my small company that makes beige
cable knit sweaters
we only sell between amagansett and sag
harbor
oh it's gonna be okay i'm not even in my
home i'm actually in guatemala
this is another character this is
relatable it's
we've all been her okay it's the woman
who can't scratch her face
i really wish i could scratch my face
right now
i love cardi b this is a total
non-sequitur i think she's so fantastic
i feel like she is so interesting and
and brilliant
and um she's taught us a lot about
female physiology that we were fair to
talk about
but um this is what i imagine she
actually is doing
in this time okay
[Music]
so a lot of y'all know me as the canary
in the coal mine for the pandemic when i
yell
corona virus corona virus
well listen i have two weeks
so i just figured that i will do a
little collaboration y'all with fashion
nova and merc
and i created a vaccine y'all oh
it's her party's corona cure
and like you guys i'm so happy you're
like
i am so blessed that you all love me and
support me
but like you'll be hating
i know a lot of y'all be like damn cardi
what do you know about
immunology a lot i know a lot
all i know is that when you get your
first dose
your t-cells are going to be like
and your b-cells are going to be like
eew
and your antibodies are going to be like
oh
but this is not your regular regular
schneck in a vaccine y'all
is super safe 99 percent effective
and we will be at every walgreens
starting on my birthday
eel
thank you guys so much for having me
have a great
safe here thank you
i gotta watch that set again let's
rewind
as jlo once said let's get loud
clap it up for that incredible set